[Applause]
[Music]
we're here
yep yeah oh hello we
live we're here we are see us where I
see us on the YouTube do you really I
do I'm waving to the people on the
YouTubes oh my God you're right we are
alive my God kids you caught us we're
still I was still doing
pre-show a lot of people died this week
but we'll get to that later man before
we do
anything
let's take this moment kids to say
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernard
hey
oh um so much to talk about so much to
cover getting I'm on a deadline because
I'm gonna get on a oh normally I point
to an invisible watch but I do have a
Fitbit I'm going to get uh on a plane
tonight from Los Angeles and fly to New
Jersey to interview the Russo brothers
that's that's right
cinnamons um pop that up there JC if you
got it uh yeah man that's tomorrow night
in New Jersey if you're anywhere on the
East Coast I think there's something
like 20 tickets left um join us 8
o'clock Friday nights M Castle Cinemas
I'm gonna sit there and interview uh Joe
and Anthony Russo talk about their
careers ask them about all the Marvel
stuff we're going to talk about
tonight ready to get to the bottom of
their Feud with Martin Scorsese
my
God that well um yeah man come on out
it's gonna be a good time I'm gonna ask
him questions you can ask questions oh
what mered times uh they'll be two of
the biggest directors on the planet
coming to SM Castle cous kids that's
tomorrow night Friday night no November
2nd 3r 3rd uh 800m Man tickets at
smodcastle
cinemas.com and then the next day I'm
going out to Minnesota for the Twin
Cities con wo you're a flying man and
look at that look at that M rat's lineup
man me Jay Muse Jay Lee Jay London Jay
Ethan S um and a bunch of Clerks cats
gonna be there so if you're anywhere
near Minnesota home of the M rats but we
shot the picture [__] come on hang out
and [__] like that but in any event uh
tonight we're going to go I got to stop
at 9:30 so I got to grab my bags I tail
it to the uh to the airport man and head
back
East I always get nervous saying that
like um you know just remember remember
the Buddy Holly
Story I mean I the real thing but the
movie like doesn't in my head the movie
ends with him going we gotta catch a
plane and it's the Richie valin part of
it right like Richie valins was deathly
afraid of flying it's like this one's
going to be fine we got to get back to
whatever it's like okay I guess I'll
Trust it that was a scary I know we just
came from Halloween and [__] and uh
everyone should be talking about spooky
stories or were the other night but when
I was a kid that terrified me I don't
know if it was The Buddy Holly Story the
one with Gary Bucy but there was a movie
about Buddy Holly where it ends with him
literally saying on stage AG like we got
plane to catch and knowing what happened
you know in real life as a kid I watched
that movie and I was like they freeze
frame on his face and I was like is
[__] terrifying [__] 70s and the
80s were full of freeze frames that were
[__]
terrifying really knew how to end a
thing back then um kids yeah how was
your Halloween Mark what you did you did
I see you went to like Jim Lee's house
for Halloween I did he has a he has a
party oh he used have a party every year
then took like six years off but I guess
he did not Purge the roles of the uh of
the the guest list and so I I got the
nod and went back to uh to to to Mr
Lee's house dressed up as Morpheus from
uh from The Matrix it was it was it was
a Warner Brothers themed party and given
that I'm no longer on strike I could uh
Avail myself of the costumes from the
studio and uh and yeah found like the
one black dude who's not a superhero and
and uh and dressed up like him and had a
lovely time I'm just going to go back to
like you're all tight with Jim Lee
enough to go to his house and
[__] might happen uh I I don't know
really I don't know but uh but no Jim
Jim has been I've been in his peripheral
orbit he's been in my central orbit for
like 15 years now um ever since I
pitched him a comic book and he said yes
and uh and yeah so he invited me like
I've been to his house to watch Star Tre
movies he's a giant
treky um how do we get how how do I get
invited to
[__] if you wanted to go I'm pretty sure
you can reach out I can't go as your
guest like what if you show up with me
and he's like if I Mark come here if I
wanted him
hereit
here he's dressed as Silent Bob again I
know he wears the same costume every
year of his life
just I get it it's screen used I know
are they having a Captain Marvel
Premiere you think
um I think they're having fan events is
what they're calling them now how do we
get invited to a [__] Fan event I
once again the giant comic book movie is
coming out and I feel like we're persona
non gr I'm not complaining I'm just I'm
asking how do you how do you get in on
sem reaction I'm just
curious less than what is it 10 days or
something like that until yeah opens
next this Friday next Friday the
10th um so much to talk about tonight
kids indeed yeah hard out at 9:30 hard
out at 9:30 so I can't playing go back
East talk to the Russo Brothers man but
tonight talking to Mark Bernard right
here on fat man beyond kids and as as
per usual somebody's paying for that
indeed we would like to thank uh our
sponsor kids
fume head to trif nume.com tr R YF m.com
and use the
code fat man I bet fatat all one word
yeah to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today the journey pack
comes with three unique flavors and the
new version two fume to help Kickstart
your positive habits kids that's try
fume TR R yfu m.com and use the code fat
man to save an additional 10% off on
your order uh today be smart don't start
man kick the habit and put it out before
it puts you out all phrases we've heard
hundreds of times yet we still continue
to do the bad habits man um our sponsor
fume kids there on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits consume far too many of us
fume is a natural diffusive device that
uses plants and behavioral nice to use
plants and Behavioral Science to help
you trade out your negative habit for a
positive one fume is not a vape it's a
non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits man
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chem like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious flavors man fumes
new version two model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap your fingers will
always have something to do always have
something to do Mark takeover the
easiest way to stop a bad habit is to
switch to a positive one and a fume is
designed perfectly to do just that it's
fumees goal to make switching easy and
even enjoyable they have thousands of
five-star reviews from people just like
you who've successfully switched when
other Solutions just didn't work so head
to trif nume.com tr fun.com and use a
code Fatman at checkout to save 10% off
when you get the journey pack today
Journey pack comes with three unique
flavors like Keb said and the new
version two fume to help Kickstart your
positive habits that's try fum
f.com and use the code fat man to an
additional 10% on your
order uh we thank good folks of fume for
sponsoring this here show man go chest
test them out kids indeed um Tri fume TR
R yfu m.com okay yeah you been watching
anything I have been because I've been
sick man oh no and not with the coid I
took tests and no Co but like I've had a
like a head and chest cold that I have
not been able to shake it's not not like
killing me or weakening me or whatever
like you know two weeks ago you know I
had a kind of rough first day but well
again not not Co something must be going
around but even now like I was blowing
my nose earlier today and like real
[__] thick yellowy [__] came out
which is a good sign
so well actually it is a good sign is
that true it is because that is when
your body is attacking it and expelling
the germs that are in it it's bad when
it's just clear clear is like we're kind
of [__] up but when like you're
coughing you're expectorating and when
your snot is all green and [__] that's
the bad stuff getting out of you so it's
it's not of
progress there it is man I'm getting
better we learned a thing [__]
thanks wizard um so I've had time to
watch some stuff uh shall we
start with Loki we absolutely can CU I
just watched it like
literally you know [__] less than
half an hour ago
episode five yes I've not seen five yet
I'm still I'm still on four or I've seen
like maybe I should hold back on five
because how many people are that current
yeah yeah yeah especially because even
technically West Coast you're not
supposed to get it till 9: no six
o'clock it says on the Disney channel
nine o'clock east coast six o'clock West
oh yeah you think Disney give me
anything or anybody anything
[__] well let's see how do we I mean we
could talk about four you saw four right
I saw four um and I and and like listen
I I liked the first episode quite a bit
because like I didn't know what was
going on but that's fine because it was
the Mobius and Loki show and I like I
like going Wilson I like Tom Heston I
like watching them two together like
it's cool it was fun catching up with
old friends as the show progressed I uh
I I stopped understanding the little
that I understood about what was going
on um and more to the point I didn't
know why anything was happening like it
seems to be a show at least up until the
end of episode 4 that was about saving a
bureaucracy a bureaucracy that I didn't
really understand the need of or the the
the value of like we got to save the TVA
like I don't care I don't I just I kind
of don't like I I am invested in TV when
it's about character um and it was it
was always maddeningly frustrating to be
like what does Loki want in any episode
what what does he want what does Victor
timley want what does mobus want what
does anybody want other than this kind
of McGuffin Chase of we got to get the
thing to put on the loom to open the
blast doors to stop the
whatever I'm like I don't know what that
is like unless unless you attach it to
character unless you attach it to
emotion it's just a thing they're doing
and too much of the show has felt like
just we're doing stuff
we don't know why we just kind of are
um I think it's
six so tonight is five tonight is five
and then the 10th is the yeah the 10th
is the no the ninth is the finale is
that for sure only six episodes
yeah
um they
uh it seems like they're building their
sets
no there's a lot of like construction
happen there's a lot of like we we we
built this cafeteria we built this
whatever not a lot of volume shooting on
this like we recreated in 1982
McDonald's just because we kind of
wanted to they shot there a few times
they use that again this episode um
episode four spoiler warnings kids we
saw Victor
timley
um you know uh meet some sort of
end of the the
um how they undo people MH they it looks
like licorice or string theory just
gbly yeah somebody said online posic um
cool as the you know dusting
was from uh from Thanos like watching
people doesn't seem like as horrible
death
man you're just lazy it's just kind of
like turning into spaghetti and [__]
there's something kind of sweet about it
um it looks like what Scarlet Witch did
to Reed Richards oh that's right yeah
did you see the story this week where
they confirmed that Scarlet Witch died
in Multiverse of Madness did they who
who was it who confirmed Marvel really
like she's dead she's never coming
back of them are cut to we need
I mean like we always knew that secret
Wars was bringing if not everybody than
the people that you wanted back like you
know that that was their that was their
way in that was their like listen we
know that you're not loving this but
guess what you're going to get we will
spend all of the money and we will get
you all of the characters Living Dead
doesn't matter that's I've seen so many
[__] articles we'll talk about it
when we get to the news big article this
week from who variety yeah did a deep
dive on Marvel and uh so the internet
lit up for the last 48 hours with all
the details of this article um we'll get
into it
pretty uh pretty heavily but um you know
in terms
of I my guess is enjoy your Loki while
you got a
kids so article man like they're going
to stop they're going to reain it all in
they're gonna they're gonna they're
going to curb
like these
huge things and make
less yeah like I I don't know what else
is coming down the pike tvwise for them
I know
Ekko
Daredevil eventually yes which they
recently just kind of thrown out the
creative team or or moved on to a
different creative team I don't know how
you express it yeah um but like the the
the giant hose that used to be Disney
plus and Marvel seems to have throttled
way back um animation still seems to be
kicking like there's still some stuff
there's a what if season 2 coming
there's I think there's more Groot
coming I think they have a couple of
things that are in that pipeline because
they kind of have like Marvel Zombies I
think is coming like you in order to get
that [__] done you got to start that way
early out right like it it doesn't make
any sense to pull the plug in there
because the the sunk costs are too high
um but the liveaction stuff it's like
Ekko was supposed to come in
Thanksgiving but I think they pushed it
to 2024 Daredevil will get whenever we
get it and I think that's probably it
like I don't think there's a w division
season 2 I don't think there's a m
Marvel season 2 I don't think there's
going to be a falcon winter social
season 2 CU you get a Captain America
New World Order movie
like I think that all of those thing
like there's no Hawkeye season 2 all
those balls that they put up in the air
um they're not just sort of letting fall
to the
ground um before you
know God I want to get to that story um
so yeah let's get back to Loki so
Loki um we're
seeing some
of you know what's happening in Loki
looks like it's going to pop up and
the Marvels based on the latest Marvel's
trailer um's teaser
trailer uh shows an incursion which is
something of course that Loki introduced
us to um in Loki season 1
correct um I thought it was I thought
the first time they mentioned the word
incursion was at the end of Doctor
Strange 2 um when when Clea shows up it
already happened by before Doctor
Strange 2 came out yeah yeah I don't I
don't remember I remember I think I
think it was Loki that kind of defined
and brought us into the world of the
incursion looks like in that teaser and
a lot of Reports online have been
talking
about uh the Marvel's teaser ends
with an
incursion of the Marvels ends with an
incursion it looks like based on this
teaser I ain't [__] saying anything
one in this teaser if I am I'll tell you
where we're going after that but right
now um now again these are spoilers and
these are stories online not necessarily
this don't come from the horse's mouth
but you know we've seen a lot of stories
online come
true uh they say that in the end at the
movie they is uh I mean do we talk about
this it didn't even come out yet I mean
we we can put it under like deep rumor
SLS spoiler SL whatever yeah yeah kids
don't get shitty if we talk about this
and you're like what these are all
teasers and stuff so if you don't want
yeah it's all kind of
speculative Loki Langley Neely says Loki
has never mentioned incursions yet what
I thought they did like [__] that's I
learn the word I
thought yeah I didn't think so I thought
it I thought the first time we heard it
is when cleus shows up at the the end of
Doctor Strange 2 and was like there's
been an incursion you have to come with
me and then off she goes um but it's
also been three years since I saw Loki
season one so I can't remember nightmare
says Jim from the office was the first
to say incursion incursion in the MCU
what is Reed Richards
yeah um I stand corrected yeah no hazy
wave said nope incursian is Doctor
Strange
to everyone's saying it's Doctor Strange
to
uh they did first episode of Loki during
the animated short they said something
about incursions during
the oh boy yeah it says KV said Reed
Richards was the first one yeah all
right so looks like uh Captain Marvel's
ends with an incursion that Monica Rambo
stops but then Monica Rambo winds up in
the world that they were about to have
an incursion with and apparently in that
World
Mark
[__] there's the next
thing that's how they're going to
introduce the X-Men not all of them but
they said rumor online is that uh you
know you see in the teaser somebody
walks past Monica Rambo and it looks an
awful lot like U oh God what is the
character's name it's on the cover of
that one X-Man
issue um not entropy
um [__] but it's her mom
essentially
um uh Maria Rambo right and then they
say it's also Beast will be there Kelsey
grammar's
Beast
okay so it be uh a Deadpool 3
connection all right that's the
next but it sounds like they added it
just
recently um and that may have a lot to
do
with the
news you know the story that
broke uh the other day as it seems that
Marvel
is um trying to course correct
uh but meanwhile yeah Loki's Loki's
still happening I do like that effect I
like watching people kind of
unravel yeah yeah I just I wish I could
be excited by it you know and I and
again like I like almost everybody in
that show um but I just it it it's not
it's not character-based yet and I
haven't seen five I don't know what
happens in five I you know could be one
of those things where it's a long game
and we're giving you four episodes if
we're not sure what and they we started
to bring it home in five I don't know
yet but four episodes in and I don't
know what anybody wants um and how what
they're doing advances them towards that
game um feels somewhat problematic to me
um and again like pruning as the overall
threat that we're trying to St they're
pruning universes that's millions of
people dying like I don't care like they
haven't made a personal they haven't
made a personal in that like yes when
Thanos snaap and half the Universe goes
away but I saw half of the people that
I've been following for 10 years go away
also like I understood what it meant
because I saw the characters that I've
been following either disappear or the
effect of those people disappearing on
them but now it's just we're pruning
people okay I mean I guess it's probably
abstractly bad but it's not functionally
emotional for me maybe I'm a monster I
don't know
well they have two more episodes to get
you if you're right because five is up
now right six is truly the end then two
more to grab you I you know
I'm I'll watch now I'm just watching for
him become one of my favorite actors in
the
MCU yeah Tom Heston to [__] do this
[__] every episode throw his hair back
yeah there I think there are whole like
Tik Tok accounts devoted to that Loki
Hair Whip I mean it's kind of it's kind
of darling as I said watch it every week
I'm like he did it again there it ising
game to be had from that [__]
thing he tilts his head you tilt
yours so yeah loi's still happening kids
uh you know I I like the first round of
Loki and um I think I this one
is you know the first one had that
Wicked like [__] when they cut the
when the time Lords or whatever the [__]
were revealed as MH puppets and it had
that wizard [__] like it was just a real
rabbit hole and this one doesn't feel as
much like a rabbit hole but I'll watch
him and everyone else he a strong cast
yeah but there's a lot of you
know lot of lot of there's a lot
of there's a lot
and yet not
enough um do you see bodies I have not
seen bodies is it good I'm fantastic
based on DC comic book apparently really
based on Comics um graphic novel or like
a vertigo series I'm not sure I'm
somebody in chat will let us
know oh my Lord so [__]
watchable um you know per like when
Netflix picks
like sometimes they pick so insanely
well they just know what we want to see
man like [__] you know squid
game
um [__] Tiger King or
whatever you know they've had many
stranger things obviously um fton and
[__] but this is definitely just one
of those things where it's like
designed to as soon as it's the first
one's done you want to pop the next one
in they're [__] laay potato chips of
a show very well acted cool idea the the
idea is in four different time periods
in White Chapel England the same body
appears in four different
eras cops from four different eras are
trying to solve the mystery of who this
[__] is time travels involved it it
like from where it begins to where it
goes you're like oh [__] like I remember
watching it being like like there's no
way this ain't like based on a Sci-Fi
novel or a com and sure enough somebody
was like it's based on comic book I was
like oh my God it's
fantastic um great cast uh you know if
you if you're one of those people was
like I love British
procedurals and I don't care what error
they happen in
h of riches this is gonna be for you
totally worth your watch I don't want to
say too much because spoil it but oh my
God it's
uh they go some really interesting
places with with all the story lines and
all the eras and and the ultimate
storyline that takes it all you know
makes everything function it's some good
[__] you would appreciate it tell me is
HG Wells a character he honestly might
as
well it's honestly I would put it up
there with time after after time oh
terms of time crime movies oh nice well
done I mean this is a series but it's
worth your time bodies
un um I watched uh the Beckham
documentary Series yeah about David
Beckham it's phenomenal it's it's
phenomenal in the way that like BS high
is phenomenal in that if you know
nothing about football um like I don't
um the story is still but the the thing
about it is is he was also a pop
cultural figure he was a pop cultural
Titan if you grew up at a certain time
if you were alive in the world at a
certain time and like him and the
romance with Posh Spice and the the
advertisements and the commercials and
all that [__] like he was about as
famous as famous can get and so the way
this documentary directed by of all
people fiser
Stevens um yeah it takes four episodes
to like just not only tell you the story
of of him as a as a footballer and what
made him special and what made him um
one of the best to ever do it but gets
under the hood of him and Victoria gets
in the hood of him and fame and
Paparazzi and moving to America and his
relationship with his own Fame and his
family and his kids and his wife and
it's it's fascinating it's fascinating
highly
recommended um you I mean if anyone's
going to make me give it a shot it would
be you yeah yeah no and Jen will dig it
also I think I was like sliding past
that tile but now maybe I'll take a peek
I did see something online
about she was talking about they're
together someplace and well we came from
workingclass families and he was like
hold
on drove to school in and she was like
well Rolls-Royce but he's
like he like shouts him from the other
room he like o tell her was your father
drove you to school in like well we had
lots of cars no tell him what he drove
you to school in
Rolls-Royce and then the door closes he
just
walks like where's his was he a rich kid
growing up or no he was not a rich kid
he was not a rich kid at all but he uh
his father played some football but his
father was it's it's like every sport
story you've ever seen where like Dad
presses the kid into doing the thing
that the kid may or may not really want
to do but makes him great like makes him
like you're going to stand in that
corner you're going to take a corner
shot if you don't hit the crossbar we're
doing it again and again and again and
again and all of that repetition all of
those hours on the pitch would make him
part of you know one of the best players
ever to do it um but yeah didn't grow up
rich like just kind of grew up working
class but then suddenly at like 19 years
old is making all of the money in the
world um all right [__] worth
checking out
football um football has been
very
goodh all right should we get into the
into the Marquee topic yeah I was that
everything have we we watch everything I
mean is everything watched yeah I mean
I'm sure oh no I saw what did I see I
watch pain
killers I don't know with Emily Blunts
and S watch
um and I watched something else what was
it well you texted me about train to
Busan you were like yo train to Busan
holy
[__] last year two years ago two years
ago for his like top 10 for the year
trained to Bo I was like oh I gotta
watch that one day [__] one day we
were clicking around I was like train
the boo on I was like you know Mark said
this was pretty
good holy [__] that was wonderful
I just finally watched train the buan
holy
[__] um yeah man that was [__] really
good um what else did I watch I watched
painkillers I watched pain Hustlers
Hustlers that's what it is um and there
was one other thing that I
watched It's escaping me but there we
watch some [__] all right let's dive in
the news because this is the whole
reason we're doing this before I have to
catch a flight back East to talk to two
movers and shakers from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the dudes who made
endgame for heaven's sakes the brothers
Russo Brothers tomorrow night it's mod
Castle Cinemas come join us man if
you're in New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania [__] if you're in
California get on a plane that's what
I'm
doing pick their brains be like hey
man how do I how do I make a
movie
that um Marvel Mark do you have the
article there um I've I've got the
pertinent parts of the article uh
written down in my head and my heart uh
it was a piece by Tatiana seagull for
variety you know her you know a lot of I
do I worked with her at The Hollywood
Reporter
um I did in my previous life I was gonna
say man you know these people now you
know the players involved look at you
going to Jim Lee's Halloween party knows
the lady that wrote the [__] Marvel
article even even connected man moving
and shaking baby see this this this was
a beautiful friendship I remember in the
beginning I could open doors for Mark
now Mark could open doors for
me hear me come on in Kev GNA be at your
Christmas
party ho ho
ho guess who's here he's gonna be like
Mark if I wanted silent here
all right so you vouch for the author of
this piece some people in chat were like
hey man that was a hit piece it didn't
seem like a hit piece to
me no I mean I think that that the the
issue that happens with all these pieces
is that the journalist has some of the
all of she has some of the picture but
not all the picture um and so was
beginning to draw conclusions based on
the part of the picture that she can see
and so I think that if all of it isn't
entirely accurate like there was there
was a bit about blade um and it's Focus
there was one draft that blade was like
the fourth tier character was focused on
all these women and and go let's let's
address these charges one by one all
I'll say is like the screenwriter who
had been on blade and who wrote a draft
was like I never saw that version of the
movie I'm not going to say that it
didn't happen after I was on it but it
definitely wasn't in any of the parts
before it was on it so it's like but are
the problems on blade absolutely so it's
one of those like I I she might not have
had every bit of information but enough
to draw conclusion that seems to Bear
out with fact so we'll start from the
top yeah let's hit one by one Jonathan
Majors Jonathan Majors So based on these
this story that came out apparently
within Marvel and this was one of the
aspects of this story that like broke
the internet yesterday and
today um when charges were filed against
Jonathan Majors or or when John of the
major legal troubles began you know
Disney all of the every all the world is
like what's Disney gonna do and
apparently you know everyone's like
Disney didn't do a thing because he's
Victor timy's in
Loki but according to this article there
were discussions where they were like
look if we have to Pivot away from Kang
we could go right to Dr Doom
we could you know like uh apparently
Marvel has an annual retreat in Palm
Springs where they kind of go and
usually it's a bit of like hey look how
awesome we did look how everything is
great what are we doing next what's the
plan what's our five sevene plan and how
are we progressing on it but apparently
at this time the uh the most pressing
issue was Jonathan majors and and
basically what to do with him given that
they seem to have built this entire
phase around Kang to the point that like
one of the Avengers movies is the Kang
Dynasty and so what do we do do we
recast the way they recast Terrence
Howard with with Don cheel do they
change the actual character I mean and
they were also backed into a corner by
the writer strike to a certain degree
which is oh uh we have this we have this
Loki show that if we rewrote it now we
can maybe diminish the Kang we can maybe
figure out a different way into it we
can maybe pull some of this stuff out
but there was nobody to rewrite it there
was nobody to re-shoot it so they were
kind of trapped by the by a machine of
their own devising um and they were also
somewhat um nonplused by the fact that
quantam Mania did not blow up the way
they thought it
would um box office wise and critically
um Ant-Man and the was Ponto Mania did
not Sizzle it did not land the way they
hoped it would um bu that
yeah yeah yeah like they were like oh we
thought we thought this was great off
guard the word is they were like what
what do you mean yeah like how you
didn't like this we we we all internally
think it's amazing and then the audience
was like no we actually don't agree um
and so one one top dealmaker who's
quoted in the piece says Marvel is truly
[__] with the whole Kang
angle um and they haven't had an
opportunity to rewrite until very
recently but I don't see a path to how
they move forward with
him you know and right now the other
thing is do we just pivot to somebody
else do we pivot to Dr
Doom um somebody online was like Dr Doom
deserves his own runup but it's like
yeah and this will be it yeah you know I
mean it's they're going to be making a
Fantastic Four movie of which I would
bet you dollars to Donuts that Doom is
the bad guy and so you know this would
like would be Loki and then at some
point in the next two years you get a
fantastic form movie which can then re
contextualize where Kang is in terms of
the next three or four big tentpole
movies for them somebody's asking in
chat if something could be done about my
audio is it
bad um I think it's only bad when we are
kind of talking at the same time and I
think one or both of us drop out when
that happens but I don't know what we
can
do um okay
what else is in that article um the
Marvels seems to be uh also a bit of a
crisis point for them um the movie cost
about $250 $250 $250 million to make and
it's tracking to open to about 75 to 80
million which is not just far below what
Captain Marvel grossed but it's even far
below the 185 million that doctor
strange 2 took in last weekend um
and it seems to have been I mean they
keep talking about re-shoot as a bad
thing but Marvel has always built in
time to do additional photography
because that's how Kevin feige likes to
make movies and it's worked incredibly
well for him in that go shoot the movie
you want to make bring it back we'll see
what's missing fige will say we need a
beat for this we need to beat for this
we need a beat for this they go back and
they get those beats and they complete
the movie that way so it's not re-shoot
based on crisis it's just their process
um um but I think you know and and
according to this piece eyebrows were
raised again when director ni dasta
began working on another film while the
Marvels was still in post- production
the film makeer move to London earlier
this year to begin prepping for her
Tessa Thompson movie
heta um if you're directing a $250
million movie it's kind of weird for the
director to leave with a few months to
go says a source familiar with the
production also seems weird in the like
yeah no everybody's doing four jobs at
once and so and also let's be honest
like
um you know I believe I you know I I've
never been like I've never made a movie
big enough to walk away from smaller the
more you have to [__] be there to
bring it home and [__] like that and you
know for me I start dialing out of a
movie Once I have the cut but s cutting
while we're shooting the movie basically
like two days after rap I got my cut and
I'm like ah and there it is and then the
rest is kind of like you you hand it
over to people that mix it and stuff
like that
so you know I'll start thinking about
another project before the Project's
done but I've never worked on a gigantic
movie so I can't you know necessarily
speak to that that being said when I was
a kid and I don't think it's gone away
but you know one of the biggest film
stories of my youth was Stephen
Spielberg
left Jurassic Park before it was done to
go work on Schindler's List and you
know it's not I saw a bunch of people
going after the director being like Oh
you go oh my God I can't believe the
director walked away You're you know
these movies are not all tour driven
films in as much as like without that
voice how will we be able to finish the
movie as we've all known for the entire
run of the Marvel Universe the there's
there is a voice of authorship behind
all those movies but generally speaking
it belongs to Kevin fogy um and in a
world where it's like you've got tons of
special effects to produce and whatnot
you know like a director getting ready
to work on another movie that I didn't
bump into that part of the story at all
online seem to but like that's that is
not like somebody who's not doing a good
job that for in in the big case of those
big movies particularly with directors
who are in demand you know they they've
got a few irons in the fire but but any
thing that i' oh look look who it is
kids it's B man B man I'm just gonna
point out also Francis veropa left the
conversation to make Godfather 2 both
nominated for Best Picture in the same
year or one after the other I think so I
mean there is precedent for it even at
the top of the toop directors going back
50 years yeah and I don't think it's a
case so much of like leaving one to do
the other because Spielberg as I
remember was like overseeing post on on
one while on set of the other like he
could be in his trailer looking at cuts
and I don't remember the order whether
it was Schindler had been wrapped and he
was doing post on schindlers while doing
Jurassic or vice versa
but like yeah it's multitasking at at
the highest level and when you're
dealing with this kind of thing when
you're dealing with this kind of career
and when you're dealing with a Marvel
movie when to your point Kevin you're
not you know it's not like you're
slicing frames of film yourself it's
like you're getting cuts from direct
from an avid and you're looking at stuff
and you're sending back notes and you're
giving notes on score you'll be there
when you need to be there but otherwise
it's
emails film these are movies by
committee I I don't think I'm saying
anything out of order um you know it's
it's you've got a lot of people working
on these they have directors don't get
me wrong
but you know there was a reason that
Edgar Wright was like no
thanks making Ant-Man he's used to being
the voice on the movie The you know the
the vision behind it and when you jump
into the Marvel pool you're taking on
somebody
else's ongoing
Vision so you know in a world
where you're on to your next movie while
they're doing everything they
do um to finish it up and whatnot yeah
that's that to me wasn't the story was
that they did a test
screening yeah back in June that is a
huge story because correct me if I'm
wrong but I don't think they've done
that in well over a decade and maybe
they did it on Iron Man in the beginning
but they Marvel has not had to test
screen and has test tested internally
for the part of its life so the fact
that they went out to the real world to
be like hey here's one of our movies um
was Brave but I don't know why they'd
bother at this stage in the game but
maybe that shows how serious they are
about course correcting or something
like that and how did that screening go
um apparently you know they did a public
screening in Texas and the audience gave
the film quote middling
reviews um and so so yeah it seems as if
between this and the story we heard a
couple weeks ago about Marvel TV and how
they were changing the way they did
things and recognizing the importance of
a showrunner a writer who was empowered
to make real decisions um had some value
to them it seems as perhaps they're
beginning to reexamine even internally
just the way they do things um including
VFX which was another big piece of this
story um which was talking about when
the the this past February when the
credits rolled at the world premiere of
quantum Mania shock rippled through the
theater over the the the shoty CGI there
were at least 10 scenes where the visual
effects have been added the last minute
and were out of focus says one person
who was there it was insane I've never
seen anything like that in my entire
career even the kids of Executives were
talking about it and the Marvel and the
Ant-Man sequel had swapped places
because they felt that Ant-Man Quantum
Mania was in better shape than the
Marvel's was and so they pushed up the
Ant-Man production schedule by four and
a half months and then suddenly that
required all of this VFX work to be done
too quickly you know and and apparently
it and I mean I saw Quantum Mania it
didn't look great um which is why you
know 14-hour days in the overtime later
the Marvel VFX workers voted to unionize
in September um which seems to have
sparked off a big Trend in the
industry um and then you get to the
script issues which I think were were
highlighted by both She-Hulk and
blade um according to this piece in the
original Arc of shehulk um the
transformation of Tatian mus lani's
character happen till late in the show
didn't take place until episode 8 the
penultimate episode but then Marvel's
brain trust uh decided to move it up
till the very first episode and then you
know according to to a person involved
with shehulk the so-called bad VFX we
saw was because of half-baked scits
that's not Victoria Alonzo who uh who
the the recently departed head of VFX
and president of production I think her
title was bra trust that made all these
Marvel movies I think she was there from
almost the beginning yeah absolutely um
so that's not Victoria that's Kevin and
even above Kevin those issues should be
addressed in pre-production the timeline
is not allowing the Marvel Executives to
sit with the material and all the while
Marvel was bleeding money with a single
episode of shehulk costing some $25
million dwarfing the budget of a final
season episode of HBO's Game of
Thrones I mean that
seems It's just remember remember the
hey days of the streaming
Wars and we missed
it
I got a little taste pre- streaming Wars
when I was working for what was about to
become Disney plus but they were calling
the dis the
streamer the Netflix killer that's what
it was referred to internally as uh and
the Disney Channel folks were in charge
of what would become Disney Plus in
those days so I got to write a kingdom
Keeper Series and stuff so I did did get
a little piece of that streamer money in
terms
of they were just giving away shows on
Disney plus
yeah like they did
Willow yeah because when like Bob ier
left you're not gonna see Willow ever
again because they [__] purged it but
like those days of the streamer Wars are
over where they're they're like we'll
we'll make anything just
subscribe because we are the future and
stuff I it's you
know came at the right time because we
were all indoors for the
pandemic but the course correction as
we've now seen over the course of the
last six months whether it be ma Max
formerly HBO Max and David zaslov
purging backg girl and some other
product and stuff that see or Disney
doing the same with with Willow Disney
Plus or now saying that like hey man
we're going to pull way back on that
Marvel
throttle um those those days are over
man we missed it yeah we missed it and
you know some of that was when Bob Iger
left and and quote unquote retired from
Disney and left it in the hands of Bob
Chek um iger's last thing was launch
this thing with as much content as you
can like spool it all up make it a
unrelenting Fire H of stuff so that
people have no choice but to subscribe
and then in the middle of the pandemic
it was the only sort of barometer for
success for a stock price to be judged
by you didn't have theatrical grosses
you didn't really have theme park stuff
all you had was how many subscribers you
had on your on your streamer and so
while that was happening like yeah no
it's great it's stock is is flying
because we got a we got 20 million new
subscribers for Disney plus and the
World opened up again and suddenly they
real realized we're not making money on
these shows with these streamers we're
not selling ads all we're doing is
getting subscribers and we only get that
money once a month we have no new way to
monetize these things and suddenly they
began like all finding a level all
beginning to like pull back on how much
they produce get rid of stuff on the
rolls that they can get for a tax write
off and so now you're in this
contraction phase of everybody saying
we're making too many things and we
don't know how to sell it and also
welcome to commercials would you like
commercial commercial on your Netflix
now you can have commercials on your
Netflix would you like commercials on
your Hulu or on your
Amazon they're all coming because that's
how you actually make money on
television cut the
cords [__] Legacy Media fut is
apps yeah um long live the king long
live the king um and continuing on the
the script train um are the issues
they've had with blade um with Mersa Ali
signed on uh things were looking
promising for a 2023 release date but
the project has gone through at least
five writers two directors and one
shutdown six weeks before production one
person familiar with the script
permutation says the story at one point
morphed into a narrative led by women
and filled with life lessons blade was
relegated to the fourth lead a bizarre
idea considering that the studio had
two-time Oscar winner Mersa Ali on board
um this is the thing that writer Michael
starberg tweeted I worked on a draft
this before the strike never saw a
version where blade was fourth leader it
was a narrative led by women and filled
with life lessons but I suppose a lot
could have happened since I had anything
to do with it he was in 99% of the
scripts I was a part
of um so take all of that for what that
is but amid the reports that Ali was
ready to exit over those script issues
feige hired Michael Green the Oscar
nominated writer of Logan to start a new
and speculation around town is that the
studio is looking to make the film now
it's later for 2025 on a budget of less
than 100 million a deviation from
Marvel's Big spending
strategy but then again he kills
vampires like he doesn't fly he doesn't
turn into armor he doesn't have
superpowers he kills vampires it
shouldn't be that expensive a movie but
we've always felt that like you should
be able to make a Batman movie for $40
million because he's a dude in a
suit all a bunch of people online
getting mad about the fact that the
piece of the story said they might make
it for under 100 million bucks but I'm
like that excites me because that means
they'll probably let it be R and they'll
really go for it yeah um because if
they're not spending $200 million and
they don't have to make necessarily
family money clearly they're okay with
R-rated because Deadpool is going to be
it so there's a chance that if you make
that blade movie for under a hundred man
you're gonna get some [__] you're
going to get a cool flick as long as
they make a blade flick I saw one of my
favorite tweets online was about about
it and it said I wish I could remember
it exactly but it
said blade movie vampires what do you
need a road map like
[__] from
uh Bart
fig I don't know how this blade movie is
not done already like of all the movies
like that they're making this one was
made a couple times so they got a
template so it's not like how do we
figure this out it's like what do you
mean man like [__] you bring black
bring back Wesley Snipes as Whistler
you're good to
go
but yeah there there's a dozen different
ways to make this movie none of them are
overwhelmingly
complex again it's like they did they
make like nine of these back in the day
they only made
three and done right I'm not saying make
the same three like if you're like what
do we do what does he do what are his
powers like go watch the movies and
let's write a script let's go man we're
promis in
2023 it's you know what let's call John
Carpenter he'll have this done in like a
month and a half and it'll cost us $15
million just
go right uh and the last piece in this
movie in this in this story and in
variety was about like their fail safe
of like how do we get people back how do
we write the sh
and sources say they've been talks to
bring back the original gang for another
Avengers movie which would include
Reviving Robert Dy J's Iron Man and
Scarlet Jan's black widow um which you
know it's a comic book and also the
secret Wars and multiverses um the
studio hasn't yet committed to the idea
quote unquote um because if it were able
to bring these actors back it wouldn't
come cheap sources say that Downey's
upfront salary for Iron Man 3 was around
$25 million he probably got more for
endgame probably gets back end and all
the toy grosses and whatever they will
absolutely do this and always were going
to do this because that's what you get
from the secret Wars that's what a
Multiverse gives you it is not like a
break glass in case of emergency let's
spend the money get them back you're
gonna do it
anyway um so like I I you know I always
thought that it would be like 100
million to get him back I mean and they
gladly pay it be worth every penny man
you put him in a in a flick
again come on how does it not make
endgame money yeah you know and I think
that like reading this piece and then
reading the internet's reaction to this
piece which seems to have been Marvel is
on fire oh my God fire everybody start a
new um case closed it's like no Marvel
it's not on fire there are issues there
are problems that they seem to be taking
steps to correct um some of those issues
are bigger than others some of those
issues are more difficult to solve than
others um but like it's not like you
know everything is rotten in Denmark
it's like there's some stinky cheese
somewhere but you can you can put those
fires out with with some hard decisions
um and some quick actions but yeah it's
not as if everything is is is grapes out
tits up and on fire um but yeah no
issues you want to know how I would
course correct how
I would get to Secret Wars as quickly as
possible like seriously that seems to be
their you know reprogram right there um
gives them a chance to do whatever they
want bring whoever the hell
back um you know gives us gives
everybody what they want like oh my god
let's watch them all fight each other
like in Civil War but now there's even
more it's like the end of end game but
it's two hours hours
long
um also you know they paid an awful lot
of money for the X-Men and the Fantastic
Four like put them in coach ready hey
once again I hate to be this guy but if
they're sitting around going how do we
make a Fantastic Four movie they've made
a few of these [__]
things and if they're like I'm baffled
as to how to pull off an X-Men f
made a few of those as well so I don't
understand what the hold up is man like
you tell me Guardians of the Galaxy took
10 years I'd be like well of course like
[__] to build something that
wonderful of course it must have taken a
long time but it didn't and yet it's
taking this long to kind of give us
modern variations of movies that we have
seen
before yeah you know I mean I I think
that
that I think it's going to require a
little bit of of recalibrating how they
tell stories I feel like what was once
an asset which is everything is
connected has become handcuffs which is
everything is connected and like I I
appreciate it and
yet I'm beginning to drop out of things
like I didn't finish secret invasion you
know I mean I I probably will finish
Loki just because but not because I'm
enjoying it but because it's become an
obligation and I'm this person if I'm a
casual viewer like I'm not watching all
this stuff I can't possibly be
interested in watching all this stuff
and so then you run the risk of
alienating the very people who you need
to come aboard and make a thing make $2
billion um I mean so I think that they
have to kind of reexamine especially on
the TV stuff how hardwired all of these
stories are in together um I think they
just as they're going to pay whatever
takes to to get Downey back they should
pay whatever it takes to get Marcus and
mcely back like those two guys from
Captain America the First Avenger on
were the spine structurally and
emotionally of when those movies worked
um um they they left with the russos and
joined agbo as sort of as like heads of
story um I think they're working on
their own things but you know I think
like when those guys were humming and
when those guys give you Winter Soldier
and Civil War and infinity war and
endgame and and they understand the
spine of that story structurally and how
to make it
work like come on like put them in Coach
pay them whatever they ask for because
that's kind of also where things have
been floundering structurally they don't
make any sense and they don't tie into
each they don't build to anything um and
those guys know how to do it um so yeah
I there are issues the house is not on
fire but there's smoke um and there's a
there's a handful of things you can do
to fix it you know
including yeah make the
um Ben bamboo in chat said bring back
favro too hey man no no arguments here
yeah fa favro made one of my favorite
movies of all time Iron
Man um
well lots to think about a lot of people
in chat are like hey don't rush him with
the X-Men good news is nobody's
listening to
me never do so don't worry about what
I'm
old man shaking his fist out of cloud
and [__] but uh yeah uh a lot of folks
are like don't don't rush it do the
X-Men
right yes of course we'd all like that
right at the same time pretty pleased
with [__] Wolverine on
it tiny Canadian on top that's how you
keep the excitement like you know
somebody in chat early on was like they
should have had the X-Men and Fantastic
4 ready to go introduced at the end of
end game like that would have been
amazing I don't even know if they owned
them at that point I think they might
have but
like smart business but I feel like you
know they were like look man we got all
time in the world like you know you make
Guardians of the Galaxy and you turn
that into a
hit don't you think like you could I I
would assume that I'd be under the
impression I could do
anything um that's how you get to
eternals like and not by because saying
anything about the quality of the movie
itself but like of all the characters on
a very deep bench you're you're CH you
know you you're choosing a set of
characters that very few even hardcore
fans knew much about and that seemed to
be a bridge too far yeah um and that was
all also like you know post end game we
were still in the thrall of like man oh
man I can't believe they stuck The
Landing but now you could see everyone's
like where's
Thor what happened like everyone back I
mean I also think that like endgame was
an ending that we never got to have and
they just kept going and I like you know
what if you guys had just taken like two
or three years and like figure out what
the [__] we're doing figure out what's
next make us miss you a little bit maybe
drop in a Guardians 3 because that ends
that story you know that that the the
fall out of gorah dying like that ends
that story we didn't need love and
thunder that doesn't do anything for us
we didn't need shangi or the eternals
really you know Doctor Strange to okay I
guess but probably not like none of
those movies really scrats the itch
other than the Spider-Man movies because
they gave us Spider-Man give us more
spider Spiderman we love [__]
Spider-Man and those movies didn't need
to tie directly in to what happened once
you get Tony Stark back once you get you
know not Tony star once he once he dies
at the end of end game and once Peter is
living with that that's that Koda it's
it's deal with the characters who died
and then the characters who that impacts
which is Spider-Man and Peter Quill but
everything else felt like chuffer that
you could pull right out of that and not
even miss a beat but we needed to miss
it let an ending be an ending and then
find a way to do a new
beginning
um yeah yeah it's always easy out here
to be like you know they should have
done yeah yeah and it's hard when I'm
sure Disney's like we spent $8 million 8
billion dollar buying Marvel where's my
Marvel money I'm supposed to have Marvel
money every year and you're telling me
I'm not going to have Marvel
money they don't have enough
yeah they paid their you know for itself
yet absolutely in terms of what they
paid for Marvel what they've made
absolutely you know they they made what
15 movies Under the Disney Banner two of
them being Infinity war and and
endgame and black panther yeah they made
their money
back um well enjoy Marvel
kids like they're gonna they're going to
start thinning it out on
us
yeah which is how it was when we first
got it like you had you had a movie a
year
maybe um you gotta make a miss you you
know what I'm
saying indeed I think they were starting
to feel to a bunch of people like more
homework than anything else
so nobody likes homework no but I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm
there I'm I'm I believe they can write
their ship I mean personally I'm not
like they're in [__] trouble like
nothing like other than what I pay to
see the
movie and I'm a fan of this material so
like I'm happy to see wherever they go
but you
know they can they could definitely
be getting into the X-Men universe and
the fantastic for a lot quicker for my
taste
yeah
um couple quick bits in other news very
quickly other news I mean I saw a
trailer I saw two trailers today B guy
with Ryan Gosling looks great which uh
is scored by a bon Joi
song yeah it is in a big [__] bad way
uh in a good way but like it's all
throughout that trip trailer um and for
those of us who grew up watching the
Fall Guy on TV it's kind of exciting
I'll watch do anything at this
point um then I saw a trailer uh which I
don't know if I was supposed to see but
it's it got online for terrifier 3 oh
yes which is set at Christmas
time looks good I've never seen
terrifier one or two and so probably
won't be seeing three oh really really
good
like that Damien kid is [__] talented
man that's there's some really great
horror movies and he own horror icon
with art art
clown um all right what other news we
got uh real quick in chat said there's a
new plan of the Apes trailer as well
yeah Kingdom of the plan of the Apes yes
looks good I mean they figured out how
to do monkeys um I mean look God God
bless him but I'm always
you know I grew up
with uh Rody McDow and rubber
makeup even though their mouths didn't
really move that much they just kind of
moved a little bit that makeup was
brilliant and you forgot maybe because I
was a kid but like you forgot that that
was a person under there and stuff and
you know now it's like full out CG
effects and stuff which you know great
of course March time progress but you
know it was really hard to convince us
that [__] was real using rubber makeup
and they did it they did
it like [__] old Manning it where I'm
like used to be better in the past I get
it special effects are cool but these
these plan of the Apes movies could cost
a lot less is what I'm getting at my uh
one of my favorite set memories was
visiting you on copout and uh and Tracy
doing his oneman rendition of Planet of
the Apes lawgiver yes you made a desert
of
it like every day on that
show the forbidden zone was a paradise
and you desert of he he would like
literally do it every
day you like Tracy do the do the
thing what thing you
know a happy memory man I forgot about
that that was a
good uh Nicholas Cage apparently did not
know he was going to be fighting a giant
spider in the
flash he uh he said that when I went to
the picture it was me it was not me like
when I went to go see the picture it was
me fighting a giant spider I did not do
that that is not what I did um he said I
showed I went to the shoot a scene from
maybe an hour in the suit looking at the
destruction of the universe and trying
to convey the feelings of loss and
sadness and Terror in my eyes that's all
I did um he said everything else they
invented in
post um he's like I had no dialogue so I
had to convey with my eyes the emotion I
was onet for maybe three hours like I
don't know what happened but they wanted
a giant
spider I think what you know they were
like look man just stand there and look
at the world as it fall falls apart and
you know he was like yeah I can do that
and he did it he was like all right bye
and then I think they were like I mean
that's all they needed him
for could make a guy a Superman that
fought a giant spider you know I think I
don't think they shot in a cage and
they're like hey what if we added a
giant spider gotta assume that was
always going to be part of it yeah I
mean whether or not apparently to him
they never told him about a giant spider
so whether that was always the plan
whether it was they cut it together like
listen there got to be something more
than this and so they're like all what
if it's what if it's a giant spider do
we have enough Nick Cage to do that it's
like yeah we do sure
yeah
have if they knew it in advance or they
knew it afterwards they should have been
like hey man we're gonna have you fight
that giant spider
like but apparently he was surprised by
it yeah like tell a brother what we're
doing
here um speaking of Superman Superman
and L on the CW is coming to an end um
with its upcoming 10 episode fourth
season which will Mark the end of the DC
era at the
CW that's it huh that's it the end of is
that technically that's still part of
the arrow verse right or the beran
definitely the bran verse I'm not sure
if Superman debuted in
Supergirl and Supergirl was definitely
yeah so yeah yeah I think that's the
last vestage of the arrow verse or the
berlan verse right there so they're in
season 3 right now um they're in
production on season 4 um season coming
up this will be the last you know and
they already did the thing where they
they took some serious regulars and
turned them into recurring they Trimm
the episode count they shed a couple of
writers um you know all of the signs
that like we are not going to keep doing
this and we are cost cutting and we're
pretty sure that if we get another
fourth season we can sell it its
syndication or it'll do well on
streaming because it's got enough
episodes to watch but yeah this is this
is the end of of what had been the
pillar of network television which was
the arrow verse the bran verse DC on
network TV yeah when uh DC wasn't you
know [__]
um before there was a Multiverse in the
movies there was a Multiverse and the
berlan verse that
was the
mainstream but it was before the Marvel
movies that's for sure yeah those are
work on a few of them I
directed four super curls
and three flashes or two flashes and
three super curls I think I did three
flashes um but uh
man good time
indeed um and that's it for the news oh
hey bman is here this isn't uh big news
but um I was scrolling Facebook and an
old coworker from like 20 years ago
who's really into the MCU posted a thing
which was uh he went on Reddit and he
did a deep dive into the day that Tony
Stark's funeral took place which is
apparently October 30th 202 23 so he
found on
Airbnb the cabin that they shot the
funeral sequence at and rented it on
October 30th 2023 and he and his family
bought a 100 in screen and
projector and and watched by a campfire
at Tony Stark's house uh the uh infinity
waren endgame on the day he died
how cool is that that's very cool that's
good use of time and money right like
like we're all fans but that's a fan
like that guy is a fan how cool is
that where is that cabin anybody
know he didn't say he kept I think it's
outside of Atlanta I think cuz I think
it was on like [__] Zillow or
something like that or or or
Airbnb uh we were just talking about the
berlan verse and there's a Ryan Reynolds
commercial as Matt Garcia points out
that they talk about Reynolds and Grant
Gustin commercial there's a commercial
with Lantern in the flash I know and
they mention it like at the very tail
end of the commercial where like Grant
comes out like hey this is our uh our
new director of public engagement
Seymour roas it's like okay hey it's
like really you always be better to me
it's like oh thanks
Hal oh that's it's cute that was
cute um it's in Atlanta they're saying
on the chat
that
wow um I guess the last piece of news um
and I'm not sure how much it dovetails
directly into the nerd world but it's
the the tragic untimely passing of
Matthew Perry yeah yes I'm very very sad
um Matthew Perry passed away a couple
days ago and boy oh
boy
it's I think he would have appreciated
seeing all the
love like
everybody you know that show is such a
big part of a lot of kids' lives and
when I say kids I mean just people
younger than me grew up watching the
show and then kids who weren't even live
when that show was happening now watch
that show so the same way like for us
when we were kids like The Brady Bunch
was a part of our lives on a regular
basis friends has been a part of you
know the pop culture the fabric of pop
culture for so long even after the show
ended um it's staying power you know you
could argue might be
even more hardcore than say Seinfeld or
something like that because there's a
whole generation of kids that love
friends and all these kids were
heartbroken you could see online I'm I'm
I saw him once in real life Matthew
Perry I was at the Virgin remember the
Virgin Mega Center yeah mega store mega
store um It's s you know at
um I used to call it the lemle plaza but
that's no longer there either Sunset
five
Plaza maybe Sunset Plaza at this point
so they used to have a virgin mega store
there and one night I went in um on new
DVD day because I would always go in and
you know
get one of
everything uh and he was there and he
also had bought a stack of DVDs he was
in line in front of me and I was not a
friends Watcher but I knew who he was um
he was
apparently um getting ready for a deep
dive because he had a stack of them and
I respected that because I was a guy
that had a stack seemed like a nice guy
h and by all reports everything I've
read all for the last week everyone's
like what a sweetheart he was and stuff
Lisa Kudo I had her on the podcast a few
times and she always said that he was
really
wonderful yeah I mean I I I was a
friend's guy um because it was on NBC at
like 8:30 and for most of my adolescence
you know back when there were shows you
would watch with other people you know
it's like it's friends night we're going
over for Thursday we're going to watch
friends we're going to watch Seinfeld
and we're going to watch cheers or
whatever it was after that um and so
like yeah I watched it from beginning to
end I've never seen it since because I'm
it just didn't for whatever reason it's
not a sitcom I can rewatch the way I can
rewatch some others the way I can
rewatch dramas um I can watch parks and
wreck over and over and over and over
again because it just makes me feel good
um but friends was never that thing for
me but he was he was a sort of Titanic
figure along with the other five friends
in popular culture for almost a decade
um you know and then every now and again
you'd see him pop up in other things
like gave two episodes of The West Wing
like oh [__] good for you guy right and
he was
yeah you know Studio 60 on the Sunset
Strip I watched you just because I was a
Soren head and you
know I guess the whole nine yards and
the whole 10 yards um Fools Rush In like
he did some some somewhat remarkable um
movie work but he's always a friends guy
and the the the quote that was
circulating the day he passed um was
very much sort of a quote from an
interview that he had done within the
last couple of years where he says like
I know that when I die um you know
friends will be at the top of the
obituary um he's like but i' I'd hope
that I will have done enough work um
with things like the Perry house and
things like talking to people about
recovery and and you know substance
abuse and finding your path and finding
your grace like like i' I'd hope that
that stuff would at least make a mention
because I've worked very hard on myself
and I've worked very hard to to be able
to extend myself to people in need in
the way that I was in need um which was
just very sweet and Bittersweet in the
way that that every time a person looks
down the barrel of their own mortality
and finds an interesting thing to say
about it um you know is always touching
and sad um but also speaks a lot to the
progress that he had made in his own
life because he would this like I can
watch any episode of Friends and tell
you exactly what my problem was at the
time it's like that was cocaine that was
opiates that was too much food that was
speed like just by looking at his face
and his weight like you could tell what
he was struggling with like there I was
clean and you know to have that kind of
perspective on yourself and on your own
life is uh is is somewhat
astonishing made a lot of people happy
indeed
um sad 54 or something like that 54 yeah
man um Bull from Richard
Maul from
uh of course to us in this world Twoface
Harvey Dent himself from Batman the
Animated Series goodbye
Grace he passed
away what a legend as you know night
talk about a sitcom that we watched a
lot growing up yeah that was Night Court
um who else somebody uh somebody else
passed away as
well um I'm sure chat will remind us um
it's always a few seconds behind
[Music]
um oh my God Chad is reacting like oh no
not B says Danny McGrath oh shaft
Richard rree passed away Richard
Roundtree yes an absolute
Legend um you know not the first to ever
do it um Melvin Van Peebles is in the
acknowledged very first black
exploitation movie um but shaft was
huge sweet sweet backs badass
song um but no round tree and shaft in
Gordon parks's you know seminal movie
was the one that made the giant cultural
impact was the one that made everybody
realize it was money to be made by
catering to to a black audience and he
was the definition of [__] cool and
and remain so kind of until the end of
his days
and a
Legend um nerd tropolis pointed out Bert
Young from Rocky
also um and of course Suzanne Summers
since the last time we did a
show childhood fre company was a massive
massive
show um and she remained like popular it
feels like in almost every decade she
was like a
Stallone right like in the 90s she had
step by
step there was like Thigh Master she was
she was a permanent fixture on the
landscape and what a long marriage she
had yeah it's 50 some odd years I think
to that dude you were always seeing her
and her man on talk shows and whatnot
they seemed very
happy um yeah suzan Summers huge part of
our childhood yeah passed away baby sock
rocker is Melvin related to Maran
people's dad Melvin is Maran people's
Dad
yeah
[Music]
um Bobby Knight passed away yeah I'm not
a basketball guy but I do know who that
is that's a shame um Professor
Dumbledore what's his name Michael
Gambon did we talk about that last time
I think we hit that last time
yeah
um SciFi siif this says getting older is
interesting you're not kidding
man o when my dad um was my age and he
would talk about like you know oh my God
I can't believe John Wayne died oh my
God I can't believe this one died like
all the stars of his
childhood it's now happening and and
we're next we're the stars of somebody's
childhood mark
I'm sorry for your childhood
man one day they'll be talking about
us uh but hopefully not tomorrow because
Lord knows I'm gonna be in New Jersey
talking a good ass time yeah you guys
want to join us come to SM Castle
Cinemas tomorrow
night uh as I sit down and talk to the
Russo Brothers we talk about Marvel talk
about their very stored career you know
they directed you me and depri which I
don't know that same time as clerks too
so I'm gonna be like thanks
guys 140 million at the box
office um yeah don't forget kids I'm
gonna be in Jersey and then Minnesota if
you're around this weekend I'm gonna be
there on Saturday me and the Mall Rats
me and the clerks come take pictures get
stuff signed Twin City Comic Con Twin
Cities Comic Con
kids
um there it is yeah man I'm gonna go
catch a flight my friends go do
that we uh have no show kids without uh
the
lares of bman who Took time on his
Thursday night to hook us all up so we
could talk about the geeky stuff um but
there's no show without the
guy down in the corner and in the other
Corner uh give it up for marvelous Mark
Bernard everybody thank you
sir uh and there it is kids a short one
tonight but you know covered a lot of
ground there it is we are uh we're out
man for fat man beyond tune in next time
no [__] how how the [__] do I in this
show
um I'm Kevin Smith and I'm Mark Bernard
next time same fat Time same
that Channel sm.com or youtube.com
kevinsmith Jeff's kiss everybody see you
in New Jersey and
Minnesota this is theat greetings
everybody and welcome to the AKA ask
keev anything every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and S Bob
get old up Kevin Smith J